non-minimalists
i am a writer and often review and cover
beauty products for various publications
i am constantly getting free products in
the mail and at events
i love receiving them but it's stuff i
didn't realize i wanted in my life in
the first place
sometimes when things are free i feel
the urge to hold on to them or the
appetite to acquire them even more
i try to give away stuff to friends but
sometimes with items like these it's a
sanitary concern to share something i've
used
i hate to just throw them in the trash
some of these items cost a lot of money
even if i didn't spend any of my own
money on them a lot of these things are
just in case items
they occasionally give me value but not
always any thoughts
so aaron uh while we were listening to
this you looked up at your dad and you
said uh
i said that sounds just like you did
well i wanted to talk about this because
you're you're also in a unique position
you get a lot of stuff people want to
give you guys stuff
we've even been told that gift giving is
a love
language i totally disagree with that
but i'll explain why i disagree with
that
i think contribution is a love language
and sometimes the best way to contribute
to someone is
via some sort of physical thing but
often
we think it's a shortcut but there are
no shortcuts in fact
this doesn't even seem like a stuff
problem to me this seems like a
commitment problem so so we're saying
yes if we say yes to everything we
say no to the most important things and
so by saying yes i'll take that you can
give me the free thing you can give me
this you can give me that um we we keep
saying yes to that but then what are we
actually
saying no to we're saying no to the calm
or serenity of
of of the lack of clutter now you all
you you work in a space your building is
stunningly minimalist it's aggressively
minimalist and i love it i absolutely i
i think
what you have done is is astonishing and
and so how do you though deal with a lot
of this
how do you say no to some of these
things the first thing i say is claire
nothing is free it
no one sends you anything for free
you're just paying it with a commodity
you're not paying attention to
and if i could maybe just even use an
example with i don't know if you're
allowed to name particular products but
like i've been really huge
on duolingo during the quarantine
learning portuguese
and uh and i found myself after 150
straight days
being addicted to not being able to
break that streak
and so suddenly i'm doing something
that's free and it's actually good for
me and i'm learning portuguese
but i realize ah wow they tricked me
i'm addicted to their affirmation
that little little alarm comes on you
have 150 days
streak you know don't lose it you're in
there and so what has hap
happened this week is i had to stop
myself
and it's so hard psychologically and
and and so i'm letting it expire so that
i lose my streak so that
i'm in control of what i'm doing
and i think a lot of times it happens
you get free things and you think
they're free but they're not
they're taking something from you you
just have to decide is is what you're
being
offered worth what you have to give up
for it
yeah aaron you deal with getting free
things from time to time and it's
enticing right
not for not for me i throw his free
stuff away all the time
i don't throw it away i give it to
someone else
to be clear it's easy to get rid of
other people's stuff it's easy to get
yeah i'm the guy i buy the same t-shirt
like again and again and again i we talk
about this all the time i'm
cons i learned this from you i i get rid
of
so much my closet is iraq if you went to
his place
you would be uncertain if anyone lived
there
after how many years a decade you
finally brought a you you bought a debt
a dresser and it took him 10 years to
decide to buy a piece of furniture
right i've had a couch the same couch
for the last 12 years i've had you know
i bought a tv because we do a lot of
television stuff but
but yeah no i don't i don't really like
free stuff to me is a burden
i'd rather something be worth buying
because that for me is like actually a
transaction that i take very deeply
free for me is unwanted unless it's like
uh
time like i love and i think time is a
gift like the gift of time is huge for
me
but but that isn't i don't have to throw
it away later so i think what happens is
we we
confuse our resources right we we see
money we know that's a resource because
you can hold it in your hand you can
hand it to someone else
i can't hand you my time that's a
precious resource
and there's no refund for time that is
poorly spent
and i think the same is true with our
attention right
our attention is probably our most
precious resource because you can spend
time together but if there's no
attention there then the time isn't
worth
as much right and so i think what's
happening here
is we're we're saying well you know what
claire yeah you're getting some
some free stuff and we all have problems
holding on to things to certain things
sometimes it's stuff sometimes
it's toxic relationships uh sometimes
it's addictions we hold on to a lot of
things and i think the first step to
to to letting go is loosening your grip
and realizing you might have some
boundaries up as well
because for me my boundary is a pretty
strict one i don't accept any free stuff
from corporations or whatever just
because
we're the minimalists and like it would
be a strange thing if i'm like
you know that's why we started out each
podcast with advertisements suck
because it just can you imagine us being
on here talking about like
well and this we're brought to you by
this mattress or these penis pills or
whatever it happens to be and it's like
well wait a minute like
does doesn't that actually say you
connected the mattress with the pills
i'm sorry go ahead
that's good so um claire you did mention
the just in case items that's one of the
rules we have we have this rule called
the
the justin case rule it's one of 16
rules that we have in the minimalist
rule book it's a free
ebook that you can download the
minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version that's now available for
purchase ryan and i record the audiobook
but we did like
like 16 different mini podcasts with
each different rule that we have
i think that'll help you out a lot